[Music]
[Music]
this
hello good afternoon good morning stormy
our resident american and hello
guess who's back davey's back
hello who'd why did i have dave back
i don't know he didn't i didn't i asked
him
i just got this like it just appeared
i've been trying to remove him all
afternoon he just keeps coming back
yeah
did you try rebooting
i need to turn it off
davis back because we've asked him and
he said yes oh well welcome dave
thank you everybody
today we are transmitting
on the sidetrack channel and our new
channel which is actually our old
channel the machine
um
we used to do the brief history mystery
and we used to do the mystery machine
shows every week when we talk about
mysteries and blah blah blah we stopped
around christmas
because me
um but we're getting going again so this
week we are on the sidetrack channel and
we're on the mystery machine channel
please if you like the nonsense we talk
about over the next hour or so
go over to the machine
it's the link is in the description and
subscribe to that and join us next week
for
nonsense
there are also links to stormy's
channel
and cyworks and dave's channel
darius lives
guys we would love you to go subscribe
and support the channel as always
and
this is basically gives us an
opportunity to talk about stuff that's
not sci-fi
so anything else we want to talk about
this is the channel for that
so how are we
i'm doing well
i'm doing cool doing good
yeah i'm doing good
right well as we could talk about
whatever the hell we like
i'll start
um
james bond
they've picked a james bond not official
yet but it's going to be apparently
there's negotiations going on at the
moment but there's going to be a james
bond and it's a black fella
so british black fella to be fair he's
english as well i'd be more worried if
he was welsh
a welsh james bond no not happening
but i don't think you i don't i don't
think it rolls off the tongue as easy
taffy bond does it
or something like you know
um
it always amazed me when sean connery
was james bond and he didn't sort of
like go brew iron brew so i think yeah
that's all that's
all this scottish drink really and yeah
and also and also mars bars that are
cooked in the deep deep fryer don't
don't don't forget have you ever heard
of this stormy
the mars bar cooked in a deep fryer yeah
oh yeah
it looks like everything in a deep fryer
fish
you know like battered from battered
fish so you would batter the mars bar
and fry it
yep
um ooh
they've got their highest heart disease
um levels in europe
wonder why
but anyway pies too you know apparently
they fry freaking everything
they fry pies yeah the pies in batter
and i mean is that not just sacrilege is
that not like against something is that
not a cardinal sin against like baked
products or some description i mean it
seems completely out of harder to me
though
i don't want to alienate any of our
northern cousins
um there is a line it's the border we
shouldn't cross it but they
cadbury's creme eggs are like cocaine to
me um i i realized i had a problem with
cadbury's green eggs that um i went to a
shop and bought six and by the time i
got home i only had three left and i
only lived about a three minute walk
away
so i realized i have a problem with
these damn little lovely eggs they deep
fry them
and that makes me angry
i i met a guy
this uh just down the road from where i
rehearsed and he came into me and he's
always acted like a little bit you know
supercilious
yeah and every now and then he will
ingratiate you by acknowledging your
existence so that's always nice but you
know one day i thought i'm going to ask
this guy what he does i mean he's got
this air of self-importance it must be
something really good you know and he
said i work at the university so of
course
i'm massively interested now i want to
know what it is it says well we
developed scanning techniques oh no yeah
okay so what is it you're scanning it's
over last week we scanned a cadburys
cream egg
so i said
surely we already know what's inside
cream eggs i mean we make the things do
we not you know i mean it's no mystery
what's inside them he says well we gotta
have some way of getting a grant so
apparently the invent scanners are
invent scanning techniques to scan the
inside of chocolate products jamie so
maybe you should invite around to your
house they can stick you inside and see
what's in your belly
i know it's in my belly
popcorn mostly i went to the cinema
really ah
saw the new harry potter dumbledore's
gay
and was it any good
better than the second one but but yeah
i enjoyed it it was okay
grindelwald i just wished johnny depp
was still grindelwald i'm not a huge
johnny depp fan but he was glad he was a
better grindelwald
did you guys watch any of the footage
yeah
um
at the moment
i got to interject this oh my god the
craziest [ __ ] from that whole thing was
you know had pictures of you know his
setup when he'd store coke
you know ahead of the straw for to snort
the coke he had a tampon applicator to
snort the coke have you seen the photos
of her that she's there's a load of
instagram photos with her and a sexy
friend with with
the [ __ ]
tampon applicators sticking out their
mouths like it's a thing
like like in the kids
rolled up twenties a a yesterday they're
so old fashioned nobody uses them now
because you can't roll a bitcoin so i
guess tampon applicators
that's interesting because did you did
you say sorry did you did you ever see
the interview she gave when she she was
um
some kind of like deposition or
something in front of a court there this
might have been last year you see how
psychopathic she was
well there's a behavior panel reading a
um
you know a body language or non-verbal
communications we like to call it
everybody just in case you're interested
um and
she's absolutely so i just thought i'd
slip that in there she's just so
massively impassively aggressive you
know and
even back then i'm thinking to myself
i'm fairly sure you're going to come out
looking like the bad one out of this
particular uh
nonsense
didn't get i didn't get the counselor
there four sessions she had four
sessions on her own and they're four
sessions as partners and he says um the
woman said that it was a mutually
abusive but then went on to talk about
10 minutes about how she would come in
talk over johnny depp
and control the conversation throughout
no wonder he's a joke
yeah i mean
this is when they used to hide in the
toilet to stay away to try to avoid the
argument he would hide in the loo
you know i mean that is i mean how far
is man falling
we hide in the loop he would have been i
might have more respect from if no i was
going to say something really bad that
would have suggested he slapped her but
no you just never hit women just don't
but i mean
no i don't hide in the loo either it's
like
there's a there's a middle ground there
in there
um but no at the moment she's coming off
as a complete psycho and he's gonna say
something that
might not win me many fans here but you
know it probably is the best place for
johnny depp because i've always thought
he's full of [ __ ] anyway
well he's definitely full of drugs
well
he comes over as he's lying on the
deposition um i thought initially but
then you actually heard some of the
recordings of them in the counselor
sessions you know that's just how he
talks he's like really
slow
and and and
and and and then he just and
so
it sounded like he was trying to find
words in his deposition i was like no
this guy's just brain is so
done in over drugs over you know 30
decades or whatever
you know i used to think the very same
thing about ozzy osbourne
you know right and it's just like okay
dude his brain's fried and he has a
sister that's really religious
very never touched anything she talks
the same way
i mean that was a very very good
impression that by the way i felt like i
was actually in his presence for a
moment
and then you learned
talking in tongues this whole time both
of them
but if i saw it on like a
mtv
some sort of documentaries like oh my
god they he's not high
his sister talks the same way
maybe she was high too you don't know is
that how they talk in birmingham i guess
it is it's just people from the from the
midlands really yeah
i'm from the middle east oh so that's
well
it's just down the road for me it's
about 20 30 minutes down the road for me
so i was there last i was there on
sunday watching a show
at the n.i.a
my wife maybe
i think 30 minutes 30 minutes away me
means you you're in safe territory you
know
i'm just far enough away that we don't
have terrible um
accent are accented
boys
i'm gonna go look at some tune please
now and then we're gonna do kimberly
so i don't quite have that because
um
there's a reason why if you become if
you're from birmingham and you become a
pilot they make you go through
lessons because could you imagine your
pilot coming and going
some of your pilots today we're going to
be flying at like 50 000 feet
for like uh six hours you would all be
jumping through the windows trying to
get off that down plane you'd be like oh
my god it's the thickest bit it's just a
thick accent you just sound stupid when
you use the axle but we're just far
enough away that we don't have
the terrible accent
um
i'm actually considered quite posh
for my area we just say all right a lot
and then tell for all three things that
um all right is you know how in hawaii
aloha means hello and goodbye
that's all right for us so we got all
right all right all right and
but it's like it's the question and the
answer
it's uh it's the strangest and
everyone's your mate all right
just everyone's for me um but that's
just that's an abyss
it means um hello and how are you
artists
um but only in one small part alfred the
rest of the people in telford go what
you're on about so that's how i think
just just in the doorly part abyss
gotta love it at least i'm not a
liverpool i wouldn't be able to do
youtube before i was living bullying
nobody wants something downward i said
again i didn't understand a damn word
you said i need to adjust my speakers
here hang on a second
for accent
it came through i don't know what it was
it's gonna be i should turn it off and
turn it back on again
it
works for everything
that's the golden key to it
i'll turn mine down slightly i'm very
light switch it on and off again
right so anyway black james bond because
do you want to get this me and davey had
a quick chat about this and we have very
different opinions
so dave you just you just throw it there
what is your opinion on
a black actor an english black actor
playing even though he's got a very
french name that makes me more angry his
name's renee like who
um or jean i'm not talking about elba
anymore no he's uh well you'll have to
watch my video about that but elbow
hasn't been considered for a couple of
years
now his name's um
reggie john paige
is his name
he was in the series on netflix last
year called bridgeton which was very
popular oh
he's um
he's got the part because women want to
make love to him
um but we'll come back to that because
i mean you know
yeah i was going to say that if that's
the if that's the only remit that gets
you the god that the job of james bond
then why is it me
exactly well we were talking about that
earlier we are sex gods why aren't we
james bond i don't like martini that's
one problem
um surf and tiff the machine is because
this is going to be a different channel
um
we'll explain scripture i'm saying we're
on sidetrack today we won't normally
we're going to normally be on the
machine this is going to be our channel
where we can talk about whatever we like
other than
star trek
so
in future you'll see us very happily on
the channel the machine there's a link
in the description
go subscribe right now
do now yes
yeah or else
as my mom used to say i found out what
or else meant once by the way when my
mom threatened me with or else it wasn't
good
no no i found out on
many many occasions what rls meant
unfortunately
normally it was an empty threat remind
one and then i found out once um but
anyway
dungeons and dragons which is in
post-production
dungeons and dragons is in
post-production with uh chris pine so
captain kirk is playing that i'm really
looking forward to that
i like the first movie though and i
think i'm the only one
i think we talked about that last time
we did it we've talked about it before
we i really liked it um but anyway yeah
duncan's dragons it's it's looks like
it's going to be cool but anyway bond
we'll come back to instruction
so what is your
opinion on dungeons and dragons uh not
intentions
that's where you brought the subject up
go ahead
my opinion on dungeons and dragons
the james bond thing is you know for me
it doesn't mean it doesn't really matter
per se right okay it doesn't matter who
who you cast
um but i don't think it's down to that i
saw like
you know we're in we're in an age where
it and a society where there's there's a
lot of virtue signaling going on
and i think a lot of it's based around
that rather than you know he he's the
best guy for the job
um and it's for me it's nothing to do
with the color of his skin i don't i
don't care about that i'm not i'm not
interested in that if the if the only
thing you've got as a human being the
only thing you've got pride in is the
color of the skin and and where you're
from you've got some kind of
nationalistic pride then quite frankly
you're a [ __ ]
you know if that's that's the only thing
you've got to be proud of
are we like
on the machine
no i don't think so tell us shortly
24 7 right here i think oh there you go
we're all crusty three old guys right we
don't give a [ __ ] anyway yeah
right away a little dog just don't say
the c words there are two c words you
can't say for the love of god
i see there's conservative and what was
the other one
no
in fact you said the most the worst one
out of the two quite frankly i think
it's
15 minutes man
two thousand thousand subscribers off
the back of that one comment
and then a good example on the channel
oh well i was going to say is uh
basically my take on it is if it's about
virtue signaling and just trying to like
you know revamp the the franchise to
meet him with current social norms if
you like then it is for the wrong reason
by the very same definition i don't see
anything wrong in in developing a
character
um in their own right
and just starting something refreshing
in all honesty as well this is nothing
new as far as i'm concerned that kind of
thought process because i think there's
too many
reboots there's too many rebuilds
there's too many um you know like look
at friday the 13th quite frankly that's
just checking the mickey really isn't it
part 624 i mean after the first one or
two it's like yeah okay
uh and you know i mean i don't know a
great deal about this particular like um
concept i mean
i'm pretty sure ian fleming only wrote
so many books anyway um so
yeah
you know if we're going to the truism of
what like um ian fleming were going on
about then i think we pretty much
drifted away from that many years ago
uh so it's not not about who or what he
is just
why it's being done if you know what i
mean
what do you think storm
what's your instinct your initial
thought
um
i think it's like tim allen
you know
yeah
a lot of my
sea friends here in the united states
think it's just a tragedy travesty it's
just you know virtue signaling
you know but if you
you know lightyear is a very very very
big
character for the disney verse you know
for pixar yeah
if you look at you know what you know i
think anybody would say you know the the
leads of those films is probably you
know tom cruise and tim allen certainly
but if you look at the the movies that
tom cru not tom cruise [ __ ] tom hanks
makes
right they're all blockbusters i mean
you know we're all tearing down the
walls to go see them or stream them or
whatever
tim allen is not a draw if you look at
some of his stuff you know that he's
done
in terms of just acting the the uh i
mean there's one they that was so bad
recently that
they showed it in israel once and never
showed it again and it never even went
to dvd
do you like galaxy quest though
yeah but how many years ago how many
decades was galaxy quest let me go look
great
um
how many sitcoms
was you know 23 years ago
know hollywood it's yeah you know how
much did you last movie make that's what
you are
you know but tim allen i mean he just
can't carry movie and here disney was
probably going to spend 200 million
dollars 300 million dollars probably 150
million on production another 150
million on marketing
team allen can't carry it
argue that uh i'd argue that as far as
galley i know it was me you said galaxy
quest but as far as that's concerned i
don't think tim allen carried that
anyway i'd go with uh
you know like alan rickman and sigourney
weaver were probably the ones who
carried that well yeah yeah yeah
everything that he was in god rested and
you know and galaxy quest was an
ensemble like toy story not
you know the tim allen show and anyway
uh the like his tv show which is okay
gets okay ratings but it gets okay
ratings from us you know people my age
that don't spend any money on anything
at all so how profitable is that
well in that case i'm taking that point
this this new chap he's a relatively new
actor he's he's not particularly well
known
this is mgm's biggest franchise it's the
it's the biggest thing they own um
getting the bond now it's owned by
amazon amazon are very keen for this to
be the big relaunch
they're using an actor that nobody knows
i i didn't know his name but i knew his
face as soon as you said bridger turned
into exactly who you just had to say
bridgette and i knew who you're talking
about just broke my pen
but so you know you know here we all
think well it's got some other kind of
you know
crazy conspiratorial reason why tim
allen's not going to be the light year
the voice of light year i think with uh
this page guy
i think it's kind of the same thing for
one thing you've got to start off young
they're looking at probably a 10 15 year
run
you know and if you listen to some of
craig's comments he says get god i can't
physically do it anymore you know he
liked to do a lot of his stunts and
stuff so you got him
time to die
they had to throw money at him and so i
think if you know he the the two things
that at least primarily is a you have to
live through it for 15 years be able to
physically stand it for 15 years
and you got to be good looking
you know and
his acting skills is decent on bridgette
i thought he was very very good he's
very engaging you know and
it's just i'd never thought of his oh
he's supposed to be the white guy
i just don't know what the the plan
apparently with mgm and has been for a
while is that obviously after daniel
craig bond is dead
so
we're going to see a much younger james
bond
yeah it was the main reason why did you
sell but tom hardy a couple of other
actors that were apparently were
interested aren't going to be doing it
yeah it's going to be this page fella um
the black thing for me i for what i
don't think it really matters too much
for me i'm i'm with dave really i i
think the skin color really doesn't
matter if it's relevant to the character
though obviously it does one example i
had on the comments when i put this on
my community page a couple of days ago
was well you can't have a white shaft
character in a new movie you know one
because it's samuel l jackson we all
know that shaft um but also you know you
couldn't cast a white guy in that
character
does that argument hold war
is it the same
i mean yeah
i think it is
exceeding story i mean the only reason
i'm saying that is it you know i mean
the limited knowledge of like shaft i've
seen one or two of the episodes that
were out like the original runs and
stuff
i suppose it it'd be similar to having a
white hooky bear
on star skin hutch she's just the the
very essence of what the characters
is supposed to be in its inception if
you like our conception
suggests that that is the accepted no
but then you know is it about changing
what's accepted and what is the norm
i i think it was
and i'm just looking at this through the
lens of american culture i got no idea
how to be looked through there
uh
shaft was definitely a black character
you know yeah
there was a tv show here on in america
in the 70s late early 80s i think no
maybe the 70s called banach
right about a second no was that okay so
i forget the actor's name but you know
he was a polish guy right and that was
the original the fun of it but he turned
out to always be the smart you know he's
fighting against uh you know fighting
against the uh the big good tree of
whatever's in earth you know he's
fighting against that all the time he
always turned out to be the smartest guy
and shaft here it was kind of telling
the american experience you know which
times is not that pretty a lot of times
it's not that pretty especially when it
comes to race relations
and he was you know shaft you know had
to be in a in a urban town and had all
those same themes and so
if you i don't know if you put martin
short as shaft i think it'd be a
disaster i'm just saying i think it's
just to think banach was um george
peppard
um yeah george yes i'm so sorry
i only knew george peppard from the a
team
um
you know
hannibal you know i love the atmos kids
one of my favorite tv shows um so when i
found out that george peppa is going to
be on terry hogan a tv show we used to
have here in the in the uh in the uk
stormy when i was in like seven o'clock
in the evening
george pepper was one of the guests and
he came on wearing a big pink cravat
and a big pink hat
and just very camping was he was he was
obviously a
homosexual fella
i was only about nine i didn't know what
the [ __ ] was going on
mom what's that
oh wait isn't he flamboyant i just made
oh it's through my mind but anyway
to get back to this i think the shaft
character point is that he is about but
it's it's fundamental to the character
and the story and where he's from
um you know that that department in new
york where are you from if they're not
that that
it's very fundamental as a black
character
i don't think james bond is quite the
same because i think the the bit about
james bond is
well what's core to james bond
um
the narcissistic um quite an artistic
character i suppose the womanizing the
drinking a tortured soul you know
because of how he had he loved he had
the love of his life that was taken away
from the
um he had a you know a thing of honor
that he had it was a bit warped i
suppose but these are the things that
made bond bond suave gotta look good in
the tux you know
and these are things i don't think his
skin color was like fundamental
to
who bond is
you know it's more fundamental that he
have a nice car
then
the skin color i was more angry when
they put me to bmw oh my god yes it was
it was a travesty
some would argue that it was a travesty
when they put him in a lotus
yeah at least it was you know at least
it was british
sports guys
i'm
with some kind of sailor thing i mean
you know some i don't know about the
submarine car thing and moonraker i mean
come on please sticking him in space too
they went off the rails with james bond
many years ago
i am denied about whether i should do a
video about this which i've done
obviously to edit it and put it on um
i don't know many james bond films
many james bond fills of absolutely
chewed ass that's just whether people
want to admit it or not they really have
it was nice to see uh richard keel uh
doing the jazz character that was a nice
little
thing you know and he ended up being a
good guy in the end all very cool but a
little bit cheesy he lost its way for me
after roger moore just saying
i i think roger moore was the great it
was brilliant
he was brilliant
but i thought he was better than sean
connery and that is saying something but
he had a cheeky sense of humor to him
didn't either that sean connor never
liked that
cheerful chappie um
but i mean i think that that's for me
though is what it comes down to and if
this guy can wear the tux and he can do
the suave and he can do the the um and
he's a good actor or whatever it doesn't
bother me
one of the other actors that we're
considering and apparently he was really
really wanted it was tom hardy
tom holland sorry
tom
um that wouldn't have worked
tom holland is a white guy he's at the
right age for what they want to do um
and he is i think he's he's a really
good actor but he looks 12. can you
imagine he will always look 12.
yeah yeah
this guy that they've got other than is
he's a little a little darker in the
complexion than some people like
other than that i think he fits the role
brilliantly um i i i for me i think it
works but
yeah if if if the color of this skin is
is the only beef you've got and i mean
i'm talking generically across the board
anybody who might watch this or just
anybody full stop if the only thing
you've got against the guy having the
part
is the colour of his skin then you're
the one with the issues basically that
that's the top and bottom of it and i
i i think stormy nailed it the most
important thing is as long as he's got
the car
yeah
and a laser watch
watch it goes
i don't know why i did it on the wrist
that i'm not wearing a watch on i could
have done that
yeah
practice for a ways
an invisible laser watch or something
if tom holland had the part you know his
only weapon would have been like
exploding teddy bears or something
that's pretty cool
exploding teddy bears yeah and that was
a register of other
apparently no i think the live chat is
still working in it's just nobody said
anything for a minute or two
we keep talking we don't need to get in
there um
well yeah so i think that's good news i
think um i do think people are gonna get
angry about it you know what's saying
about how they they're doing it to like
send a message though um i don't think
they are i think this is a really big
reboot it's really important and there
is such a thing that this is maybe
cynical for me but there's no but bad
publicity
so i think these producers would be
looking at this and going everyone's
getting really angry about this
yeah we'll we'll pretend to be really
angry that um you know that everyone's
bothered about this
isn't it a shame that you're talking all
you want to talk about is raised
um and although all they're really
thinking is we're getting clicks
thank you and i think that's all i care
about i don't think they cared they
don't give a [ __ ] about sending out a
message i think they care about how many
people think there you go though you've
just
in a way in a way you've argued against
your own point now because if they know
they're going to get the clicks by doing
what they've done then they have done it
for the wrong reason
if they know that it's going to trigger
people and then people are going to
click you know
yeah i think that but that's what he's
got
exactly but that's me it's a lot of
people think though it's because of this
woke
brigade they have to be woke and i don't
think it is i think they they want our
money that's why they're doing it
i'd say you know maybe i'm being more
cynical but um i don't think they give a
crap about woke ideology i think most
shows do i think they care about getting
clicks oh well
i think they do because if that's if if
that's the culture and they're dependent
upon that culture because at the end of
the day it's about bums on seats as it
were
to use it i know colloquialism it's
about bombs on seats they still want
people to put their asses down and watch
it whether it's at the cinema wherever
whatever and they will do whatever it
takes to get that a bit like a
politician they will do whatever is
fashionable to get elected doesn't mean
they'll do what's right they'll just do
what they think people want
or that give the impression that they're
doing what they think people want
ian's made a point
people will do anything for clicks
yeah i don't know if you guys came up
with like well if this even hit your
news but there's this guy
named trevor jacob a youtuber
had a pilot's license he got this old um
un-air-worthy old 1940-ish airplane
put on a uh a parachute and he's gonna
take his he's gonna fly the airplane to
um
mammoth up in uh near uh
uh sequoia national park
and he was going to sprinkle his
friend's ashes right but what he did
instead was he faked
a engine out scenario
jumped out the airplane leaving his
cameras on physically attached to the
airplane you see the airplane you follow
the airplane down to crash it crashes in
california and then he films his journey
with selfie stick in hand showing
detailing the 12-hour journey of walking
out of the los padres national forest
all for clicks and the faa just ripped
him a new one this last one one point i
forget how many millions of views that
the thing got but he
now that the faa has ruled that he did
it for clicks now the department of
justice department of the interior the
epa the state of great state of
california is always there they're just
going to tear them into it
he jumped out of a perfectly good
airplane
but i mean that's been the shit's been
going on i think these youtubers have
been tending to hate each other and
[ __ ] all sorts for years i'm wearing
a massive rivalry get clicks please
subscribe
tim
make sure you subscribe to both channels
yeah if you wouldn't mind
if
you went
if you ate one another it'd be like yeah
subscribe to me but [ __ ] him over there
the man's an idiot you know you wouldn't
you wouldn't certainly see the one
plugin this is what i think of him now
go subscribe to his channel to for him
to tell him what he thinks of me
yeah yeah there you go yeah it works
because people love a bit of content
confrontation don't think it's a thing
but ian's made a point here i was
worried for a wee bit that we might have
a jane bond
right so obviously we had a mrs doctor
who
um
this is doctor who is that right
um
i never had a problem with this because
surely it's not a human being anyway was
it was he was he a male anyway
um he's ever been a ginger or she's
never been a ginger he can't be a ginger
that would make me more angry or if he
made him welsh again that would be
terrible
um
but you know is it
does it matter
but but
with doctor who i don't think it matters
i love the line where it says but you
were a man and she gets right into his
face and goes i got an upgrade
i i love that
um it's not the only line you can love
and i'm just sorry i'm so
yeah i've got to say though
to to throw that in is a little bit
virtue signaling in it
it's a little bit feminist
you know it it is really it's a little
more yeah but i've got an old brain
i mean you know at the end of the day
she'll be doctor who is a a doctor and
gallifrey and that's it there's no no
any stipulations outside of that are not
relevant really surely i don't think so
it's just weird he's never turned into
another alien really why does he always
look like a homo sapien
um he's never he's never turned into
death
but
could james bond be a woman
would it work
you see this is it it's like
why not just eat why not just come up
with a new character
centered around that why not just have a
female agent who's very skillful she's
attractive to men now she's got all this
you know what why why do that why dick
about
just just make one in their own right
their own character their own strengths
do it we had the in in the superhero
universe this wonder woman
nobody wanted her to be wonder man
because it'd be shite
i mean you know these are reading uh
daniel craig's mind i mean he and uh one
of the other uh directors i think
said the very same thing you know why
why are or is it impossible for us to
even write a good um part for a woman
these days
i mean you know the british secret
service is is pretty you know pretty
historic it's long-lived there's lots of
stories to tell
you know she can still be 007 but does
she have to be jane bond and it's like
the uh there was a black woman that was
like double or seven for about this much
in the last picture
and she did admirably until the title
was snatched and given back to james
bond again you know i think double 70 is
just like it is a a title almost you
know well it is a title in in this uh
world
and why can't yeah like dave said why
can't we are we so unimaginative when it
comes to female characters are we just
can we just not fathom a strong woman
you know i mean they said the same thing
about sigourney weaver in alien
yeah
why why why and originally it was
supposed to be a guy
named scott
yeah she's the leader
with the cat as a sidekick i love it you
see what gets me regarding all this
secret agent stuff is you just gotta
look back through history and many soe
operatives and agents that were dropped
in france during the second world war
and even marquee fighters were women
in their own right they were strong
characters they were brave resilient
they fought against overwhelming odds
you don't need to replace
whatever with whatever to send any kind
of message are
for the clicks shall we say um
women
women sorry stomach but that's star we
said that women in strong strong roles
should be accepted anyway and why not
just write for that role in the first
place and develop a character that
people can get behind and and take on
board
i think the difference is i think for me
double 07 can be a woman and i thought
the the chick they got to play it in um
that's that's that that sounds good
she's straight away doesn't it but
the actress they got to play um her in
the time to die
um she kicked ass i thought she was
oh my god
people got so stressed about that and
there was they wanted to get as far away
from james but they literally wanted the
opposite to james bond
for that character and people kept going
double 07 can't be a woman and i'm like
well yes it can it's just a title it's
just and she kicked ass
um yeah i don't think james can be a
woman though it wouldn't work iam was
female
yeah well yeah so was uh so so was the
bride a a a strong female character in
kill bill
yeah you know um thurman absolutely ass
kicking character yeah i think there's
loads of really strong female characters
nowadays we don't see the um the female
character that just runs around
screaming like we used to a lot i think
there's quite a few female characters i
mean lara croft you know laura you know
she was great um you know there's lots
and lots of stuff from it the thing is
though i think james bond is is talking
about about things it's core to his
character what what is what makes james
bond james bond and a lot of it is
kind of the womanizing but the
womanizing is a side effect of his
psychological
the harm and he's like talk soul and all
this i think if you had a jane bond
people would [ __ ] hate her and women
would hate her
and now we can get into like the
misogynistic thing of like what's the
difference between a [ __ ] and a stood as
a you know
you know [ __ ] sleeps loads of women and
it's frowned upon a stud sleeps with
loads of women and he's a hero you know
i mean it's like and it's not fair at
all it's they're exactly the same and
it's it's it's a crappy culture that we
live in but people would hate jane bond
if they made it the same character
yeah i think if they named it like lana
peller or something 007 lana pandler and
that's a whole different story and i
think it gets over
we were married to bond
we're not married to double 07. i think
if with the if they do go reboot or
however if it's a new agent it's not
bond
you know then then um maybe it's an
opportunity to get us to love double o
seven
instead of the you know i don't know
it's uh
that's next step
but just going back to the whole locism
thing and buzz lightyear the last one of
the last films uh tim allen did i know
i'm boring
was a three geezers
not us
uh have some big names jk simmons you
know uh scott khan basil hoffman kevin
pollock
uh the world wide gross for this move
worldwide gross for this movie was four
thousand
one and 175 dollars
i gross more than that on sidetrack
yeah
yes you do
5 000
that's how i mean no one is going to
spend 300 million dollars on the back of
tim allen if he's pulling those kind of
box off the world box office numbers i'm
just saying
all right enough about a hollywood
economics for me
yeah but it was just mainly
it was mainly based around tim allen as
many of your rants have been tonight
does he upset you today starmie this tim
allen
not a big fan of home improvement then i
take it i kind of liked it no it's just
that here everyone sees oh he's just
doing it because he's conservative
they fired him because he's conservative
no because he it's you know disney
hasn't gotten to where it is today
making churning out billion dollar
movies two or three times a year by
making stupid financial decisions
you know and um
it's just he no one goes to see a team
allen movie for tim allen apparently my
only thing i was a bit surprised with
the um
with chris evans doing it though was
that he hasn't got a particularly
distinctive voice i don't think he's got
a voice for animated movies
so when when he's doing
tim allen's voice for buzz lightyear he
he created a character you know and the
voice had character and it added
something to it i've seen some of the
adverts
sevens and it's like
it's just chris evans there's nothing
you know there's not
i don't think there's anything to it you
know it's just like so that's something
that i'm sorry i'm not i'm not surprised
they changed the actor at all right and
they want to do something fresh or do
something different i just don't know
why they didn't do it with somebody
that's got a slightly more distinctive
voice maybe not but sure he sure has the
[ __ ] box office for it though
has he been in the last couple decades
like all of them you know well yeah and
knives out with daniel craig was
fantastic as well um
to get into the sequel of that movie um
i was just some some quite big actress
didn't get a part i can't remember what
it was now and she was like aren't doing
like a youtube video crying that she
hadn't got on this in this part and i
was like calm down it wasn't that good
i mean but um it made an absolute
fortune though it cost like 50 quid to
make and it made like 100 million
dollars so knives out the sequel is
going to be
huge
but
so i think we sorted that out then so
james blonde
will in the next movie be transgender
um
he she i don't know other things
there we go as long as he she drives and
aston martin we're good yeah that's the
main game yes yes
when he goes up to the um
in bar and orders a carlin
rather than a martini they will all just
go crazy
what 22 year old guy
will drink a dirty martini
shake and not stirred you know it's just
like he's we always
it's unfair because jin's my thing i
just
loved you
so there we go requests just to talk
about flat moon theory i didn't know
that was a theory
is that a thing i didn't know that was a
thing
um
will as part of the machine
talk about mysteries and all sorts but
we'll also this it's more about we want
to hear and talk about what we want to
talk about but guys get in the comments
i don't want to talk about flat earth i
mean
or anything i watched a thing about flat
earth today though i have to admit flat
earth came back into my uh
my um thingy cube
that would be a good one imagine finding
the corner i still want to stand on the
corner of a cube of a dice the human
diet you know like oh i'm just balancing
on it
and i think he's yeah i don't think
that's thinking but
has anything else been thrown up in your
lives that you wanted to discuss now
we've sorted out bond
well i mean i thought oh i thought i
thought we was only doing an hour
yeah we've got 20 minutes it's
so many things
you know we cover sometimes like what
we've watched this last week i've i've
got to report in
on a movie you made in 2014 i watched
last night that was horrible kind of i
mean there's a new tank on this but oh
my god there is one thing that really
[ __ ] it up for me
um
i've lost my train of thought what film
is go back to me i gotta look something
up
okay
you haven't even tell us what film it
was
stormy what was the name of the film
how much of an impact it had on him he
can't even remember the name of it
i couldn't remember which one it was but
it was
the suicide squad right
hey
it was it put it as uh 2021 i got
confused with another bad movie i was
wondering
we won't talk about that suicide squad
you know it's one with sylvester
stallone as a shark
you know yeah and um
out comes the bad guy
played by peter capaldi
with vacuum tubes anchored in his head
yeah it was pretty bad
holy [ __ ] was that bad
i mean it i mean
it was bad
i mean i i couldn't poop all day i mean
it was really bad
not even marco robbie wearing very
little savings
nothing nothing you know it's just
you know the crazy thing is though they
did the peacemaker tv series
and it's fantastic
it's so good i've watched it twice
really absolutely brilliant
um they do this whole um
as sci-fi well we will leave bleeding
back into sci-fi a little bit here but
as sci-fi fans i'm a massive alan tudek
fan
um i think resident evil a resident
alien sorry has just finished for me
over here it's the best sci-fi show
that's been on in years it's fantastic
he actually did the um the dance move he
choreographed the dance move for the
start but because his wife is actually
one of the producers and uh they
choreographed the dance bit at the start
honestly dave if you haven't seen it
give it a go it's just ridiculous
um but it's it's the right sort of
ridiculous that that my my
that that the silly part of my brain
just goes he
i'm a big fan of silly
oh you'll love this then because it's
ridiculous oh this one hbo max
oh we got on sky tv over here yeah all
right i'll i'll give it a go i'll give
it again i'll make it it's glorious but
there's no peter capaldi with vacuum
tubes no no that was it was it was very
difficult to watch i kind of like you
know i kind of like peter capaldi you
know his
guitar strumming you know doctor who but
no
no
suicide squad there's a lot of white
supremacy
going on
um there's um just horrific violence
really violent
and um and the gold eagle that sort of
dances and thinks it's great you can't
really argue with it it's just brilliant
and i love john cena i really do like
john cena um i think he's brilliant i
watch him with loads of interviews and
he's so funny um and it that comes out
in the series it's it's honestly i
didn't want to watch it because i hated
suicide squad
i want i would rather
put a knitted needle through my kneecap
right and then attach it to an electrode
and electrocute myself
then watch suicide squad again
um
but
i can't actually wait to watch um
peacemaker go because it's just [ __ ]
great
it's really good i'm i'm shocked i i on
your own i will give it a try i will
give it a couple of episodes
it reminded me of um it's like the army
of darkness with um
bruce campbell it really reminds me of
bruce campbell all the way through the
character and the way it is and um and
the way it puts together but
um
you know that that's what it reminded me
of and the series that they did about a
couple years ago bruce campbell that's
that's that's the that's how it feels to
me um but it's it's absolutely fantastic
um
go back to stephanie's point here which
is actually i think is a really good
point
and somebody mentioned it earlier um
there's one strong female character do
you remember like aliens
the movie aliens where they got the
marines
oh yes had the one woman i forget her
name sorry i'll have to give you guys
questions
with a massive freaking gun
was that a strong female lead or was
actually was that just she was because
she was playing
a bloke green
i don't know i don't think she wasn't
particularly strong she wasn't
where's the line how do you how did you
figure that out is it
well
playing a bloke's role or is it
well maybe that's the problem we are
looking for when we the way we even
phrase it is strong female character you
know implying that no
that
strong females kind of don't exist
if the woman playing vasquez was playing
a strong character
that's the question more suitably asked
because certainly she played a strong
character yeah
you know she
we're very with her life
and she's one of the most memorable
characters in the movie
yeah yeah yeah she
was in there there was somebody wanting
to do or i saw some place
uh stating that they should just do a
backstory a whole film on her
last week or so
and like i don't know maybe it's in
giant speaking robot and members
shouldn't like read that
site anymore but it was someplace
that i saw that yeah they should just do
a whole series on vasquez
i want to see hudson in it though as
well
but i love bill paxton yeah
but
some character was fantastic in that
movie as well they're the two characters
that stand out for me the rest of them
are a bit
um you know i was a big fan of michael b
i just thought michael b was great um
loved him in that i loved him in the
first terminator um you know he's just
one of those actors he's just a likable
actor he was terrible in that seal
movies seals movies they did but we'll
ignore that
they were michael sheen
um
you know [ __ ] film full stopped all that
really wasn't it oh god it was it was it
was made for back
yeah
they got some actors in it and they were
happy um but yeah private hudson was
just like
she's great
because but bill paxton he was that
exactly at that age you know he'd done
that and weird science that was about
all he'd done
i think if you if you you look at his
career he pretty much plays a shy talk
in nearly every film doesn't he i mean
really in a way he was massively type
cast just in his
in his personality regardless of the
concept of the film he was always a bit
of a shite
bill passed in a little bit of a coward
a bit of a gobshite you know
have you ever seen um two guns with uh
mark wahlberg and denzel washington
he plays the bad guy in that he was one
of his last roles he was really sick
apparently already during june making
that and again he played like a cia
shyster constantly sweaty and you know
just like this real slime ball sort of
thing and i'm just like yeah that's
great that's it for paxton although that
is this is the perfect that's one of
those rare movies it's a perfect movie
well picking up on mcavoy's previous
point you know like a starbuck you know
in the last besg is
well remember that how much the bee's
nest was stirred up concerning you know
a female starbuck it's just woke oh well
one woke back then it was just you know
politically correct political crisis
and she rocked man she brought i mean
that's god i mean he was just
she did wonderful so i actually saw the
the producers talk and roland d moore
talked about that a few years later and
he said we decided to do it because the
character had been done to death not
just not starbucks necessarily but
the womanizing and the smart talking and
all that sort of thing and it says
because it got to a point where the
starbuck character was boring
we didn't want to do it again so we
thought what's a way to
liven it up a bit make him a woman and
yeah but i mean because for me there was
no need to include the cigar if you're
going to move on from that character
don't keep the cigar like dirk benedict
would rock because you're not you're not
doing 100 job you just let that looked
absolutely dickish for me
yeah i think she's done a good job and
i've got every single episode of of the
on the movies you know and you know
i'm not hating on it at all i think it
was a she'd done a fairly good job of it
but you know she's just come across as
being butch as to strong as people have
said in the side chat as a strong woman
but acting manish rather than a strong
woman in her own right you know what i
mean and i don't think the cigar was
necessarily but that's just my opinion i
suppose
some point in time is used as currency i
thought
you know all sorts of things yeah cigars
plot point about the cigar you know kind
of illustrating
um the niceties of
things in you know living in the
colonies is going away very very quickly
yeah i mean the ballpark said something
like these are the last two cigars from
the you know in the in the universe they
were from the finest
manufacturers in the whole 12 colonies
or something like that
but yeah it's
and then after that i don't think i ever
saw
a cigar
maybe probably not i didn't have any but
my point is it was the producer's
reason for you and it wasn't to be woke
it wasn't to do so it wasn't even to get
clicks it wasn't anything cynical it was
we need to we need to do something with
this character because it's boring
we need to do we need to do something
else with it and i i i think all did all
they done was make it exactly the same
as the old starbuck just a woman it was
a woman acting like a man for me
[Music]
i've got every episode it was a woman
acting like a man rather than a strong
female part
acting feminine they act how you want
but it's obvious what they were doing to
me i'm not i'm not filled by what they
were doing despite what they might have
said the producers it's all over when
you watch it she acts very manly very
butch very male
you know shark cropped hair and all that
lot
make
starbucks a feminine female if that's
what you want to be doing but don't do
this
no yeah you didn't it didn't wash with
me i'm sorry guys but no do you know the
thing that
pissed me off though
well in the original battle star
galactica series there were several
strong female characters it wasn't a
dharma's water
yeah yeah
a fighter pilot and she was a strong
character i'm looking at the um the
character list now so we've got
uh lieutenant athena
um
i just love the guy that played bolton
he was just one of my favorite actors
just [ __ ] awesome uh lieutenant she
there was there were several really
strong female characters and but obama's
daughter
they just didn't bother
put her in the new series at all
and i was like well you had a strong
female character there why did you
you've made such a big deal about about
starbuck
and you've dumped a perfectly good
character there that you could have used
instead
um maybe valid
yeah
all right then guys well that is our
hour mark
yeah
and i think we've done well there to to
keep it around an hour you don't want to
discuss james callis as picard's daddy
no
sure
you had so much to say earlier in
another video about picard
i did i did a video yesterday about
picard even through snot and
through a cold
because i was so
watching the only thing that really
annoys me about that series at the
moment is it makes no fricking sense
and that annoys me
and there's too many it wanders off all
over the place because oh my god yeah it
is oh look at that it's something shiny
over there let's go talk about that for
45 minutes no just will you please just
focus on the the burger all we care
about we just focus on that please yeah
mag guys
yeah they are they're they're they're
writing magpies they're like they're
like oh you know what picard he was
angry at his dad wasn't he
was he that's never been mentioned
before yeah exactly like when did uh
picard's
when did that ever appear appear in
anything else and i was like
when did that happen
but they had that whole thing with his
mom building up to it through the whole
series and then just to know she was
mentally unwell and it's just like oh
okay i thought that was going to be
something relevant to the other story
it's got nothing to do nothing there no
it's just
three stars on amazon picard series
two's got and i think that's
generous it's [ __ ]
honestly i said at the end of that video
yesterday i am where's my camera that
close to giving up on star trek
and if strange new worlds is as bad as i
suspect it's going to be i'm going to
have to never watch
star trek again you know you'll come
back to lower decks because you love you
some lower decks
i actually can't wait
um
the best star trek series is about to
return
and i'm very excited about it
the orville
that's a star trek series i want to
watch because that is brilliant when is
that when is that
uh it's in the next couple of months
it's been like four years since the last
series
but it's coming back
and apparently and there's going to be a
movie there won't be a fifth series
there'll be a movie and that'll be it
apparently but um that's just a
conversation i don't know if that's a
fact yet or not but
that's the rumor
but um hey i love it why not and then i
want to see seth macfarlane
do spaceballs too
that's what i want i want spaceballs too
the search for more money and i want
seth mcfarland to do it because i think
is that actually going to be a thing
spaceballs too
apparently they're talking about it
um but um somebody's going to put it in
the comments now because i keep going on
about this how much i want space to do
in the movie
it's not for ian
message a couple of esco code because
yes we know it's like we know you want
space balls too um but yeah apparently
it is one of the mgm are trying to
figure out they want to reboot a couple
of movies and because star wars is so
popular at the moment they'd like well
that's a perfect way to take piss out
star wars
we'll do space balls
i've only seen the first episode
i've not i'm not a chance because i'm
watching all my kids and they're never
here so i've watched it it's kind of
bloody good oh my god i'm picking up
your euphemism it's really good not
bloody good it's real bloody lovely
bloody cup of tea
um
i like the first episode i thought it
was great yeah yeah
now i will get back to it but um i've
started to watch daredevil with the kids
and they love it so they just want to
watch that
they don't want to watch anything else
so and we haven't mentioned dave's hat
but somebody did
in
i am family you're back
and family is one of the people that
have been bugging us on the channel to
return so this one is for you sir
we're back
so we're back in family
we are
so we will try our damn this to be on
every week
um about the same time sometimes it'll
be stormy sometimes it'll be with dave
on the mystery channel
and we will talk about whatever the hell
we want sometimes we'll have no topic
and other times we'll have something we
want to talk about
talk about mysteries and whatever you
want to talk about so please guys get in
the comments of the stuff you want to
talk about or us to talk about let us
know and we we might do it or we might
ignore you completely
yeah one of those things we'll
definitely have i think we need to talk
about what bigfoot
um we're going to get into so much
trouble because you know the youtube
algorithms don't pick up on sarcasm or
humor all they hear or say is trying to
spend a
and you're going to get so many crazy
like what
i'm going to get so many emails off
youtube so yeah we've took that video
down
right because you used the c word didn't
you
and
they never believe you they don't never
believe you but um but yeah
and this this it's the return
i'm back
yeah
and now we're done
so thank you stormy you're very welcome
it's american thank you dave in your
flat camp yeah man if ever a man can
rock a flat cap
yeah man it's you i'm a northerner i'm a
northerner you know we wear flats
absolutely you know it is i just look
like in a flat cap i have to admit
but um but i put my collar up
because i'm feeling cool today
so uh
and i think i'm rocking that thanks for
everybody that's got into the comments
you've been absolute legends we will be
back next week same back time
different back channel so please go and
subscribe excuse me to the mystery
channel no the machine channel the link
is in the description
also you can go and join stormy and see
more of stormy on his channel cyworks
dave on darius lives because even though
i keep putting various even though i've
known you nowadays for well over a year
i was searching for your channel stage
trying out the link and i couldn't
figure out why i couldn't find it
is dorian's word for doritos
yes it can be
it actually came from a spirit box
session
uh well it actually came from a ouija
board session and then
subsequent subsequent spirit box
sessions um when a name kept coming
through darius so it's actually darius
it was darius lives because that message
come through on a spirit box on more
than one occasion and then because i
started to do a lot of lives it was
darya's lives and dory ass and asked
doris i've been called all kinds of
things so you know
that feels like a future episode
there we go oh yeah that's out of all
the places that question could have gone
i didn't expect it to go now i'm gonna
put a ouija board up here you know yeah
i was on a ouija board ah wonderful
the spirit board
guys thank you so much for joining us
for our relaunch it's been emotional
um been brilliant
we will see you
next time guys it's been so emotional my
heart is in tatters
i'm breaking
say goodbye dave
bye bye dave
and guys we will see you next week
thanks for joining you guys bye guys bye
bye bye
wait second i'm trying to first
[Music]